[Music]
condolences to the families and loved
ones we try to save as many as possible
but some could not be saved and I also
wish to express my sympathy with the
Albanian people for all the damage
caused by the earthquake Europe European
Union responded promptly to the request
from the government of Albania for
assistance
first team were deployed already the
same day Tuesday last week now the
search and rescue stage is being
concluded is over we are now in the
second stage which is devoted to the
assessment of the damage and this will
feed thereafter into the next stage
which will be devoted to reconstruction
all along this process Europe will stand
by Albania Albania is part of Europe
Albania is a candidate country we will
not let you down Albania will be able to
count on our support in the weeks ahead
so that we are able to get the
reconstruction underway after this after
this difficult experience Prime Minister
just last point as the president of the
Commission announced yesterday already
the Commission has already allocated 15
million euro as the first allocation for
the contribution to the cost of
reconstruction that is to come after the
post disaster needs assessment is going
to be completed now to you prime
minister Truscott sparring for morning
found in the fund that was given
yesterday's retro which you found on
keep our first you got onto our mesh
with Seema Seema burn you fall for for a
progress who burst phoned the producer
of the on which some could produce
report of vodka be CJ Fargo missionary
Oh miss Joni president they're gonna
loosen up on the lion
Sunderer may may put fossil in a port so
did I you were post castro then be
buzzed Navy report II don't really Visia
Megan is working on similar topics in
remembering her team in price family
novels from a Nazi leader our nation
that is believes Regan Smith put my
peers in conference tomorrow Donna torij
who were bleeding a from the gosh the
foam broom few more European don't yet
coordinate or speak words you
the funda to make a me know me much
Matthew my you know something offer
experts to in team safety purposes the
Baba it is properly which buildings
surrounding to the Commission okay a
question or two account the new pure
yeah yeah but the P idea you to allocate
respond damages
magic earthquake of the 26th of November
cause we're talking about the major
serious ravages but also we're waiting
for the financial estimates to take
place I'm alkylation and we're now give
a finger candy you allocate again in the
future
the thousandth a reconstruction of
buildings the first thing that has to
happen that has to be undertaken after
the damage assessment is the so called
post disaster needs assessment the
European Commission is already in
contact with the United Nations and the
World Bank in order to prepare for this
assessment to take place and only after
such an assessment we'll get the figure
the number of the needs and then the
European Union will continue to stand by
Albania in order to contribute to the
reconstruction as estimated by those
needs assessment another question No
thank you
you are all from this village
I guess you queening America yes how do
you how do you spend the night of these
days
NATO's cool for a colony in this tense
they're looking at the houses to see
whether they're safe the IO superboy
Natasha popular so entertain such as
recoilless and there is Atlantis see
Goethe for you for took fewer Natasia I
ask you for a bit of patience for new
system under the Tucker Koya as a packet
or iam shisha focus unity Rory this
really was a natural disaster so the
patient it's not it came from God it
came from
other things altogether well
unfortunately such things can happen you
never know when hot kisses Jared Attila
Adam Dahl and I see her look D had
circled all the new parish commandant
but I hope at the end all will be well
support you where do I shoot a teenager
became European dodo it happen Bolivian
averts pursue billion but basically they
have to go there where they keep the
limestone so that they can feed them so
every so often they have to go back I
came to see what is necessary to be done
as Isis fighters and I voiced my part to
Berta
so they are building houses very big
houses